For your core 2 exam, there are two
versions of Microsoft Windows you need
to be familiar with. One is Windows 10
and the other is Windows 11. CompTIA's
official exam objectives state that they
consider all insup support Windows
versions to be in scope for the exam.
And Microsoft has commonly supported
Windows for 5 years after its release.
For clarification, CompTI has
specifically written in the exam
objectives that they expect you to know
information about both Windows 10 and
Windows 11. Fortunately, both of these
Windows versions are very similar to
each other. So once you know Windows 10,
you're already very familiar with
Windows 11. We went directly from
Windows 8 to Windows 10, so you'll never
see any references to Windows 9. Windows
10 was designed to be a single platform
that would work across multiple devices.
This isn't exactly how Windows 10 turned
out, but you did find Windows 10 being
deployed on many different devices.
Through the Windows 10 life cycle, there
were more than 15 different released
versions with the last one being in
November of 2021, which is version 21H2.
Microsoft has already stated that
Windows 10 Home and Windows 10 Pro
support will end on October the 14th of
2025. Although that is the last official
date of support from Microsoft, I think
most of us realize that there are
organizations that continue to use these
operating systems past their usable
lifetime. So, you will still see Windows
10 being used in production even though
the official support ended on October
the 14th of
2025. Windows 10 Home, as the name
implies, is designed for the home user.
This is the version of Windows you would
get if you purchased your computer at a
retail store. This integrates Windows
with your Microsoft account and it
integrates the one drive backup feature.
So when you use Windows 10, it will
automatically back up parts of the
operating system for restoration later.
Windows 10 includes a very capable anti
virus and anti-malware software known as
Windows Defender, and you can interact
with your operating system using your
voice through Microsoft Cortana. Windows
10 Pro was built for the enterprise. If
you're working in a business, you're
probably using Windows 10 Pro. That's
because Windows 10 Pro includes a number
of features not available in Windows 10
Home, such as the ability to set up
remote desktop as a host on the system
that allows anyone to be able to connect
to a Windows 10 Pro device from their
computer and perform remote desktop
functionality. Windows 10 Pro also
includes full disk encryption or FDE
through the use of Bit Locker. And if
you need to join a Windows domain, you
can do that in Windows 10 Pro because
Windows 10 Home does not support that
feature. Microsoft also made a high-end
version of Windows 10 called Windows 10
Pro for workstations. If you're running
a system that has up to four separate
physical CPUs, then you can use Windows
10 Pro for workstations. This version of
Windows 10 also supports a maximum of 6
terabt of RAM inside of the system and
it supports the relatively new file
system known as Microsoft Resilient File
System or REFS. This is the same file
system you'll find in Windows
Server. And if you are in a very large
organization, you may be using Windows
10 Enterprise. This is a Windows 10 that
includes volume licensing that you can
deploy to hundreds or even thousands of
devices. This addition of Windows 10
includes App Locker, which is an
administrative feature that allows you
to enable or disable the use of certain
applications. You can also use branch
cache in this version, which is a way of
caching data at a remote site instead of
having to use a wide area network
connection. There's also a granular user
experience control or UX control where
you can define what users see on the
Windows desktop. This means that you can
control what features inside of Windows
10 are available and what features would
be invisible to the end user. Here are
the four additions of Windows 10 that
you would find. It's the Windows 10 Home
Pro, Pro for Workstations, and
Enterprise. Windows 10 Home does not
have any access to a Microsoft domain.
It doesn't include Bit Locker support.
It can only use remote desktop as a
client and not as a server. Group policy
management is obviously not available in
the home version. And if you're running
the 32-bit version of Windows 10 Home,
it supports a maximum of 4 GB of memory
and the maximum is 128 GB of memory.
With Windows 10 Pro, Pro for
Workstations and Enterprise, you can
access a domain, use Bit Locker, use
remote desktop as both a client and a
host, and you have the ability to manage
the device using group policy. And
because 32-bit operating systems only
support 4 GB of memory, all of those
versions also support only 4 GB. But
notice that the maximum amount of memory
for Windows 10 Pro is 2 terab. And for
pro for workstations and enterprise, the
maximum is 6
TB. The upgrade to Windows 10 is Windows
11 and it was released in October of
2021. One significant change with
Windows 11 is there is no longer support
for 32-bit CPUs. Windows 11 comes with a
new user interface, so the desktop looks
slightly different with a new start menu
and new taskbar widgets. Windows 11
integrates Microsoft Teams, has new snap
layouts within the operating system
itself, and it's able to be used better
on tablets using their new touch
integration included with Windows 11.
Microsoft has also built in artificial
intelligence using Windows C-Pilot
inside of Windows
11. Windows 11 Home is the addition
designed for the consumer market. So, if
you bought a computer for use at home,
it's probably using Windows 11 Home.
This version of Windows integrates with
your Microsoft account or you could
create a local account on your computer.
It of course has limited management
functionality because we don't tend to
have active directory in a home
environment. And Microsoft has included
some additional encryption functionality
within Windows 11 home called device
encryption. This is very similar to Bit
Locker, but it's designed for the
consumer market. In an enterprise, we
would store recovery information within
Active Directory. On Windows 11 Home,
this recovery information is stored in
the user's Microsoft
account. Windows 11 Pro is the version
you would use when you're at your office
or in a large organization. It
integrates with Active Directory so that
can be centrally managed from one place.
It includes full disk encryption using
Microsoft's Bit Locker functionality and
it has virtualization capabilities using
Microsoft HyperV. The Pro edition of
Windows also supports remote desktop as
both a client and as a server. Windows
11 Enterprise was built for the very
large organizations that purchase their
Windows licenses using a volume
licensing function. There are also
additional management functions built
into Windows 11 Enterprise through the
use of mobile device management or MDM
and mobile application management or
MAM. And unlike other editions of
Windows 11, Windows 11 Enterprise
supports the resilient file system,
which is the file system you also find
in Windows Server. This table of
features for Windows 11 is very similar
to the one we just saw for Windows 10.
Windows 11 Home does not have any type
of domain access, Bit Locker
functionality, can only use remote
desktop as a client, and does not have
any group policy management functions.
There's obviously no maximum memory
available in the 32-bit version of
Windows 11 because there is no 32-bit
version of Windows 11. There is only
support for 64-bit CPUs. And the home
version of Windows 11 supports 128 gig
of memory. Windows 11 Pro and Windows 11
Enterprise support domain access, Bit
Locker, can use remote desktop as both a
client and a host, and supports group
policy management. Windows 11 Pro
supports a maximum of 2 terb of RAM and
Windows 11 Enterprise supports 6 TB of
memory. If you're in Europe, you may be
familiar with another edition of Windows
known as the Windows N edition. The N
means that it does not come with any
media player functionality. Not only is
there no Windows Media Player, there are
no other multimedia utilities built in
to the Windows editions. Fortunately,
these can be added later through the
media feature pack for in addition.
You'll find this under settings, apps,
optional features, add an optional
feature, and the media feature pack.